questions
I don't know
good morning everyone and welcome to
today's planning meeting on a cold and
frosty morning I went to the 14th of
December
are there any apologies
have apologies from councilors Parker
Jeffrey Goodman Bradbury Nutley Peart
and McGregor
thank you very much indeed can we know
there's apologies with the show of hands
because I propose who the children
have that okay fair enough okay fair
enough thank you
item two the minutes of our last meeting
which is our available on page 5 and 12
of the agenda
is everybody content
yes yes so I'm happy to propose for the
chair that we adopt those minutes
and a bit second second it might so
can we go to the vote with a show of
hands in please yep okay
sorry counselor
[Music]
that's okay
okay
so
okay okay but that's Curry again that's
fine thank you
um are there any decorations of Interest
at all
no thank you
public participation we have two members
of the public that would like to address
the committee today
um the an objector is Mr Mark Gilchrist
and then also the supporter is Mrs Diane
nyeri
moving on to item five which is my
announcement
um I think the first thing to advise is
that councilor Sylvia Russell was a
reserve of this committee but now she's
been appointed as a member of the
committee by her political group so
welcome Sylvia Russell thank you
um I'm going to do some introductions
now to let you know who's who's sitting
to my left and my right
to my left is Sarah Salway she's the
Democratic Services team leader to her
right is Paul Woodhead who's a solicitor
for the council
to his right is Rosalyn Eastman the
business manager
and at the far end we have
an embarrassing this is now when you've
run out of names Cheryl sorry I do
apologize Cheryl yeah
who's actually the um the the
standard planning office apologies for
for bumbling on that one and to my left
Christopher Morgan who's the trainee
Democratic Services officer
so we have just one planning application
to consider today
and that is planning application 21
oblique zero one three five two oblique
major Obelisk Farm Kenton so I'd like to
hand over to the officer now to present
the application
laughs
thank you chair so the application
before members today is obvious Gardens
mum had a change of use of land for
sighting of 14 holiday lodges demolition
of all the glass houses except for one
which is to be retained to use the
Winter Garden
an Associated access Landscaping
internal roads decking and hard
soundings
so if I move on to the presentation just
to let you know that three late letters
of objection have been received this
week that they don't raise any new
issues they just repeat
um objections that are already set out
in the report
so just moving on to the location plan
so you can see the top half of the site
outlined in red as the application site
the land below that outlined in blue is
other land that is owned by the
applicant
foreign
which shows to the north
here this is the registered Park and
garden
so the application site is this area in
Red so I just highlighted this is the
area
um where Holly tunnels used to sit these
are the green houses there are some
existing holiday lets here
and some there and that is the
applicant's
um listed dwelling
so in terms of Heritage assets
so
um
the registered Park and garden is the
north of the site here the closest
Lister building is the Atkins own
property
and I've set out the various distances
in the report
um
but these
trying color triangles indicate the
Heritage assets within one kilometer of
the site
so that's the existing site plan so you
can see it is quite heavily treed
slopes quite significantly from North
down to South
you can make it here an existing
informal track
runs around the perimeter of the site to
the back of the greenhouses
so this is the proposed site layout just
in the corner here this is the original
proposed layout when it was 24
lodges it was reduced down to 14 due to
the Heritage concerns so this area of
the site here is to remain undeveloped
proposed access point is in the top
corner
this is the greenhouse that's going to
be retained so the the brain buildings
or The Lodges
um this cluster here by the existing
holiday properties
so I've just put up the drainage plan so
you can see what is proposed in terms of
drainage
um the black dots are existing septic
tanks so the three lodges in this corner
will drain into the existing tank here
all of the other lodges here will drain
into a new package treatment plant and
that has its own Drainage Field
um
Devon County local risk Authority and
the environment agency are both
satisfied with what is proposed
so apologies this one's probably not
terribly clear it's just it's the
Landscaping plan
so the green areas are where there is
new tree planting proposed
a powerful as existing trees and the
hashed area this is to be managed as
Wildflower Meadow you will see there is
a condition for further Landscaping
details to propose to strengthen the
boundary so particularly this boundary
and this boundary
so the app can provided some
illustrations of what the proposed
lodges might look like so they are
effectively sort of Timber Lodge designs
all designed as is in the report to meet
the legal definition of a caravan
so this is taken from the applicants
lvia and I have used some photos from
that because the photos are much better
than anything that I could take myself
so
excuse me the pink area
um is where theoretically you would see
the development from
it is quite well contained due to the
vegetation and the landform
so moving on to the photos so this the
snippet at the top here shows where the
photo was taken from
so this is the highway to the West so
the site is in here and behind the
boundary so you will get glimpses of
lodges
um on the site from the highway and this
Banger here is one of the ones that will
be strengthened for additional planting
so this is
showing the proposed site access
the new access will be going in through
the top here
the bottom image
is taken from towards the lane up
towards the car park to Obelisk Gardens
so the site will be in behind
that row of hedgerows and trees there
so the next few slides are just views
taken from further away so this is from
the East the site will be on Lower
ground to the other side of that
Hedgerow
and from the south
the access to the site is up that line
that just shows the vegetation is quite
dense it also gives you an indication of
the nature of the local Highway
so some further range views again you
can see here the existing greenhouses on
site you can Glimpse them through the
vegetation
and similarly here the site is in this
area
and again further from the south west
you can just about make out
existing dwelling and some structures on
the site so the site as indicated is
roughly
um that area
and a longer View
again I've put
a red blob there that's kind of where
the site is so you can see that the
vegetation is quite dense so it's
difficult to set Longview to see any
existing structures on the site
so moving on to some of the photographs
I took this is currently how the the
proposed site access is it's covered by
a fallen tree
so the top photo here
um that is the tree in the corner of the
photo so that's looking down the lane
and that's been the same point looking
up the lane
um around the corner you have the
entrance to Obelisk Gardens car park
and this is a photo looking down in the
lane the existing access to the holiday
lights is here
um so although there are no formal
passing places on the highway there are
in terms of
um
where the access points to the site are
so this slide I've just done a quick
route
around the site where my next photos are
because there are so many trees on site
every photo kind of looks similar so I
started
um in the bottom here
and then what around the perimeter of
the site with a few views in and then
I've gone around the back of greenhouses
so I'll just walk you through those
photos
so this is the starting point looking
um towards the greenhouses and some of
the
former Nursery structures
and that's moving around slightly
further north so you can see in the
background here this is the greenhouse
that will be retained
and moving towards the center of the
site that shows you here the existing
holiday properties
and this one moving
along the western boundary
and then this is looking towards the
center
of the site one of the open areas where
some of the lodges will go
which is taken from the towards the top
corner of the site so the proposed
access will be
um in the left hand corner this building
you can make out here is what I've
referred to
um and therefore it's called John's
house
um and these quite mature trees here are
part of the boundary with the registered
Park and garden
and that's another view of the center of
the site you can see that the trees are
some of the trees are quite mature The
Lodges will be cited um amongst the gaps
in between the trees
and this is from towards the top of the
site so this is the northern boundary
the access point will be in Behind These
trees
and then walking along the top of the
site so the northern boundary is up here
um you can see that's the existing green
hazes
this is taken from the towards the top
corner of the site so the northern
boundary is on the right here so that's
looking the access will be in sort of
that direction this is the track that I
mentioned earlier that will be reused
for the development
and that's an
um another photo to show
um how dense the northern boundary is
oh and that's this is just moving slowly
along the northern boundary
um I put this one in it was one of the
applicants photos in the support and
documents just gives you a feel of what
the site
um looked like when it did have
polytunnels on it so the polytunnels
have recently been removed
this is taken from the top
um corner of the eastern boundary we'll
be just off to the left of the photo
here and you can see that's the
greenhouse that's being retained this is
the area where the polytunnels um did
set and it's now going to be undeveloped
again that's just the top corner of the
site looking from the other direction
you can see the remains of one of the
polytos
and that is the eastern boundary which
it's it's a fairly um significant
boundary there are some gaps through it
so again that will be strengthened
through additional planting
and then just looking down so that
eastern boundary is off to the left here
and that's again that's the track that
runs
um around the edge of the site
again this is towards the greenhouses so
that the track continues down here
it's looking back up to the track we're
at the back of the greenhouses now
that's the bottom corner of the site
with the greenhouses so all of these are
going to be demolished
so I thought it'd be useful to put these
in there's there's been some
some local concern mentioned by the
objectors the history of the site isn't
clear it's been overestimated what what
did take place on the site
um we feel it would have been more of a
plant nursery rather than a garden
center so this shows you 1947 1999 there
were greenhouses polytunnels
um on site and it would look like sort
of this area of the site was once a more
sort of formal garden and for the
applicants building it appears sometime
in the history
it was divided off
this was sort of operated so separately
but it's since been rejoined and now
everything
um
in that planted boundary and belongs to
the applicant
so again slightly more recent photos so
the greenhouses can still be seen there
are less poly tunnels on the site
foreign
so that's that's the end of the
presentation so I've just put that one
up there so you can sort of compare the
clusters of Lodges of tend to go in the
open areas there will be lodges here
um and then four more lodges doctors in
this area
so the recommendation is of approval
um that is as you probably often hear
off to say a very finely balanced case
there are some conflicts of policies as
I mentioned in the report
um but it's felt that it is it's a quite
a relatively small scale scheme it aims
to boost the local domestic year-round
tourism there is as I mentioned
um here and then there's two down here
there is an existing holiday business
use on the site
and there is the former Nursery to
consider so on balance that's why the
recommendation is approval thank you
thank you Cheryl Now we move on to the
public speakers can I call Mr Mark
Gilchrist forward please
sure sorry sorry I do have a question
oh could you just point out on the plan
where the Winter Garden is going to be
please
just waiting for it to come back up on
screen
okay
nice to make something it's can you see
the mice
um
it's the top it's the top top pink
building uh I think are you moving up so
yeah yeah
thank you very much
um my name is Mark Gilchrist I'm a
consultant physician at Torbay hospital
I've got two young children we live 250
meters from the site I'm a parent
Governor at a school nearby
and and I'm delighted to be here to to
represent the local community and their
their views on this development
I would like to start by just going back
to a development back in 2014 The
Sawmill solar farm a major development
where the community was consulted ahead
of time with public meetings and there
were no objections from any private
households to that development
if we come to this development there
were no prior public meetings for what
is quite a major development in the area
and what we have is 67 objections I
think from the local community and they
are unanimous there is no support for
this in the local community and when we
look at the the application we feel that
the council has been presented with an
application that is riddled with
emissions with errors and baseless
assumptions I think you can see from the
handout that some of my friends and
neighbors have put together that there
are real concerns about the traffic
those pictures don't really give you a
true understanding of what the access to
that site is like
in some of the mitigations it talks
about providing cycle storage and the
gradients either side of that access are
in excess of 20 percent that is out of
reach to the Casual cyclist and
certainly Out Of Reach to the more
sedentary individual that's apparently
being targeted by these holiday lens
the traffic count that many assumptions
are based on was conducted in February
2021 during a period of covid lockdown
any calculations arising from that are
not reliable particularly when you
consider February 2021 in lockdown
versus a busy holiday period April to
October
and
the notion that somehow traffic will be
reduced from a site that's not had any
commercial activity in 15 years is also
a little bit hard to understand
if we move on to things related to
ecological considerations and
sustainability the council gave a very
clear steer in pre-application advice to
do with things like DNA surveys of ponds
on adjacent sites looking for Great
Crested newts instead what we have is
somebody looking at some satellite
picture saying it's probably not
hospitable to amphibians we've got a
request from the council pre-application
for about surveys between April and
October what we've been presented with
is April to June and if we look at the
bat survey that's been provided we know
that there are multiple species of very
light sensitive bats who are foraging
commuting roosting in areas where these
lodges are going to be
and we cannot see that the necessarily
the necessary legislative requirements
in terms of light mitigation
particularly from The Lodges themselves
and from the traffic have been met in
this regard
I think the community also has
significant concerns about the ongoing
management plans for the site
so many of the mitigations in the final
report from the planning department
seemed to rely on the 24 7 presence of
the applicant to manage things like the
lights out on barbecues and fire pits at
11 the day-to-day checking in ferrying
staff around to reduce traffic and I
think
the existing holiday lets have been used
in support of the application and if we
look at TripAdvisor reports for how they
are managed and the impact there what we
see is but seven reports all of which
given a one out of five rating where
customers feel that their expectations
have not been met and they describe
properties in a state of chronic
disrepair I cannot see that expanding
this property Base by seven to tenfold
is going to improve this situation so
the local community feel that many of
the representations and surveys that
have been done need to be re-looked at
preferably by independent uh
providers and if you feel that you
cannot reject this application
following that we would ask that there
are stringent conditions placed
particularly around the management
particularly around environmental
consideration that are measurable
enforceable
and would lead to the closure of the
site if they were not met thank you very
much
thank you
sorry right okay now an opportunity for
the supporter Mrs Dyer Neary to come up
in five minutes thank you
foreign
my name is Diane Neri I'm the owner of
Obelisk Gardens
uh the property which is the subject to
the planning application before you
today
I have been a resident in mam head for
the last 32 years
since 1990 and live at Magnolia Lake
previously known as The Grange
my husband and I purchased Obelisk
Gardens in June of 2007. almost in
self-defense as the previous owners were
very noisy and used a lot of heavy plant
and machinery jcbs and diggers alongside
the plant nursery
that they operated
the property was in a very run down and
dilapidated state
regrettably my husband died and life
changed
my son lives and works with me here and
we set about together to make
improvements to Obelisk Gardens
we created a holiday letting business
using the existing three buildings on
the property improving and refitting
them out and then we incorporated two
Cottages from the old stable building at
Magnolia Lake and have five cottages
eleven years later
a successful holiday letting business
catering for a 50-plus age group
has been established the the guests
enjoy
Countryside and love to come to Devon
and revisit old for haunts or simply
just relish the peace tranquility and
Country surroundings
The Cottages have proved to be very
popular
despite what has been said previously I
do have a very good rating for the
holiday occupancy and the age group that
come are very happy with the environment
Squat and peaceful
we have improved Obelisk Gardens and
planted a considerable number of
specimen trees and shrubs and cleared
away a huge amount of derelict nursery
fitments and 18 isoil polytunnels adding
luxury holiday lodges was a natural
extension of the already popular letting
business
sensitively installed they would also
complement the environment and not
damage the surroundings
holiday lodges do not entail building
construction and are not considered
permanent buildings retaining one of the
largest of the greenhouses as a winter
garden will create a local a focal point
and place for visitors to additionally
enjoy
I envisaged The Lodges to be in the
colors of the countryside muted Brands
and greens complemented by landscaped
floral and evergreen shrubs and plants
plus more trees
all of which would create more
attraction and habitat for wildlife
Birds bats and other important insects
and local wildlife
we are beekeepers
a bit green and don't allow the use of
pesticides or other Countryside killers
due to the Contour of the land and and
very little if anything is seen from
outside the boundaries which are heavily
wooded so such a development would in no
way upset the surrounding Countryside or
blight The View
our biggest contribution to the need for
carbon reduction is to ensure our
groundworks drainage and Lodge spots are
as carbon neutral as possible
lodges themselves are constructed to the
latest standards and already incorporate
carbon neutral principles wherever
possible
there will be provision for rainwater to
be collected for plants lodges will be
fitted with solar panels electric chain
charging points and bicycle storage the
guests come to stay believe it or not do
bring their bikes and they do like to
use them so we have to give them storage
we personally are and will be in charge
of overseeing all aspects of the
development living adjacent to the park
we will be ensuring the location retains
its Countryside atmosphere and is a
valuable addition to the area
we were encouraged to receive the
approval of English Heritage in in the
proposal and to hear that they
considered it would be an improvement to
a property so I I hope you look upon us
favorably we do have some very nice
ideas that we'd like to incorporate and
thank you for listening
um at this stage it would be the the
opportunity for the ward member to
comment but unfortunately councilor
Connor is not able to be with us today
sorry
so now we go into the debate members
oh yes sorry counselor again
thank you thank you chair
um can I um just maybe have some
clarification on some of the points that
have been raised by
um the objectors so
um you know a bit of commentary from
officers on um the fact that there was I
understand if it's a major application
there should be
um public consultation in the local
community beforehand and that wasn't
carried out so some commentary on that
please
um
some commentary on the management of the
site and um the idea that it will be the
owner next door is that an assumption
that it will be the only next door that
is going to be regularly
um patrolling the site and and dealing
with management issues
um or or is that going to be conditioned
I assume it can't so can I have a bit
more on the management of the site to
ensure that it does operate in in the
way that's been suggested it will
[Music]
um
kind of a bit of information about the
bat surveys the fact that it should have
been
um April to October but was only April
to June
um and in terms of landscape assessment
um the fact that a new landscape
assessment wasn't carried out
um can we assume I mean or can you let
us know that
um the The Lodges that have been removed
have been removed from the area where it
felt there was a problem and therefore
that is why you haven't asked for
another landscape assessment
thank you
yeah okay so to answer those of the
landscape assessment if I take that one
first
um yeah it's quite a new
um landscape assessment wasn't requested
um which would generally be standard
when a scheme is being reduced so
obviously it was quite significant
significantly reduced from 24 lodges
down to 14.
um
the removal of the 10 lodges from the
top corner of the site wasn't done for
landscape reasons anyway that was done
purely because they were the um
closest to the registered Park and
garden historic England had an objection
on that basis
um there has never been a landscape
objection to this so there was no need
to get them to revise the landscape work
on the lower number of lodges
um in terms of the bat surveys they were
carried out by professional ecologists
our biodiversity officer has reviewed
all of his documents she's carried out
the um South hams sack uh habitats
regulations screening is satisfied with
the level of information proposed what I
would say is in terms of the surveys the
guidelines saying April to October that
is just guidelines it's not a set rule
um quite often if a colleges can get
enough information to make an informed
decision by doing less surveys they will
do there's no need to you know go to
considerable expense to do additional
surveys that won't reveal anything extra
um in terms of site management
um the applicant is the owner who has
just spoken and has confirmed she's
living there uh you will see on
condition 19
on page three of the report
um we are proposing there is a condition
for a management scheme to be submitted
and a lot of the the issues that concern
the objectives will be dealt with under
the site license as well not in terms of
planning
um
and I think the final point you raised
was the consultation
um now I don't my understanding is there
wasn't um sort of public consultation or
events held prior to submission but as I
mentioned in the report you know the
application has been with us
um it was submitted in 2021
so that has as evidence by the objection
there has been you know quite
significant opportunity for people to
make their views held and they have done
so
if I can just follow up on that one chat
whilst consultation pre-application is
encouraged you know on any application
of any scale we can't
we can't turn it away if that doesn't
happen
um it's it's the onus is on the
applicants to engage positively with
their Community but um particularly
something of this nature where it is
Major really by virtue of sight area
only rather than
um uh because of the number of dwellings
or the amount of floor space that's
being developed with Caravan and sites
are are a use of land rather than built
development and we wouldn't uh insist on
any upfront public consultation taking
place
thank you any other members like to
comment
um it is very narrow there will be a lot
of traffic coming from visitors to the
area who are not familiar with the
narrow roads
um
it does seem as though Devon County are
satisfied with the access and the
traffic Arrangements I wonder if there's
been any further comments by the people
who live in the area about traffic
concerns and Highway impact on these
narrow Lanes
is there any further
concerns about that being expressed
the officer like to respond to that
please yeah I can't I mean I'm not sure
what you mean by further I think it is
one of the key areas of concerns that
has been raised by objectives
I know the area but this is the first
time I'm on the committee and I just
want to make sure that all aspects are
being considered here it is a lovely
area it's a tranquil area but the access
is really very narrow and when you look
at the number of vehicles that will be
coming up and down to access the site
people who are strangers to the area
then there could be we could foresee
some difficulties uh with with traffic
and people not being familiar with the
area thank you Jim
thank you and any other members like to
comment
councilor Clarence was momentarily
before you can suggest thank you very
much
uh could you remind us please uh the
criteria
uh that designates this this is an area
of great landscape value a g l v what's
the criteria uh
could we have the definition of that
area please
aglv is a local landscape designation
it's not a national landscape
designation it does apply to our
prettier areas but the inclusional
exclusion of any particular area of the
district from the aglv has not been
reconsidered since 2000 and it wasn't
re-looked at in our 2014 plan it was
rolled forward from our previous plan
but clearly this part of the countryside
so close to a registered Park and garden
and is a relatively important landscape
it's not a national designation so we
don't have any aonb we don't have any
green bell in Cambridge although
Greenbelt isn't a landscape designation
um and this isn't part of a national
park so this is a at the lower end of
landscape designations it's one up from
Countryside but it's a local landscape
designation so it's not one that merits
a special consideration notwithstanding
the fact that we have policy
en2a that talks about giving
um you know being careful that we make
good decisions in these areas which is
why we had the lvia work done and why
the size of the scheme has been reduced
and to make sure that it didn't have an
unacceptable impact on the registered
Park
I hope that helps it doesn't no it
doesn't help I'm sorry I'm trying to
tease out of you please if I may
I mean
is it does if it's designated
Countryside or if it's Elevate
designated undeveloped Coast there are
certain criterias in undeveloped coasts
which preclude development and what have
you and I I want to see I'm trying to
tease out to you please if I may what
what the criteria is for an algv that's
what I'm trying to say I mean it might
just as well not have a designation if
it's not does it preclude you from doing
anything does it no no it doesn't so the
undeveloped Coast policy and the local
plan is really clear that development
should not take place in the undeveloped
Coast unless it is for marine purposes
or if it's a domestic extension or
relatively minor development the policy
for the aglv
thanks Cheryl
um says that development to protect and
enhance the area development will be
sympathetic and help conserve and
Enhance Landscape and Seascape character
so it's it gives us some criteria about
um you know restoring the landscape
protecting wildlife and historic
features and maintaining the quality and
avoiding visual impact through high
quality design you know the criteria
that are in the policy we think are met
we are not in en2 territory for
undeveloped Coast
which says
uh new development will be regarded as
inappropriate except where so in
undeveloped Coast you start with a
presumption against the development and
you see if it fits and that's not the
same in in this area
thank you what you say in this
particular case is pretty meaningless
no I'm not saying it's meaningless I'm
saying it's not the same as undeveloped
Coast
okay thank you
sorry
well so so sorry counselor of Jew house
was actually before you if you don't
mind yeah cancer students
thank you and yes thank you just a
little concerned around the the lighting
and how the minimization of light uh
from The Lodges themselves will be
controlled in in the sense that
obviously uh you can control the outdoor
lighting
um but in terms of switching lights on
and off or drawing curtains and the like
um that that's a much more difficult
issue
um I'd also like to know why the time of
11 pm uh for barbecues was
why that particular time was chosen
please and how the management scheme
will ensure that there is actually a
representation of the
um of the management on site in the
sense that they are two separate uh
areas from from a planning point of view
and of course there is nothing to to
then stop the uh the owner either
selling their house or and moving on or
or selling the site
foreign
the management scheme there is the
condition for that to be submitted so if
the outcome was to seek to decide those
conditions and submitted a management
scheme that we felt didn't give enough
um assurances that it would be
adequately managed then we would not
agree that condition
they might be two separate areas
um but there is a there's a clear you
can walk through so that they are very
much joined in effect
um but yeah I take your point we can't
stop the applicant from selling the site
um if they were to do to do that
um the 11 pm restriction on the
barbecues that was
um at the suggestion of the
environmental health Team
um they had a look at the application
and given
um I think the nearest neighboring
property is 250 roughly meters away they
didn't feel there was significant
concern but they suggested that that
would be wise to put that condition on
um I mean if you felt it was too late
and it should be a little bit earlier
then we can discuss that
thanks so I I'd ask don't only ask that
because it's usual uh in the industry at
the 10 o'clock because obviously you
know you can't just switch a barbecue
off
um it it it takes time
people move away and and the like
um in in in terms of the lighting I'm
still just a little concerned
um that even though we would be managing
the lighting out on site uh to to
mitigate lighting impact
um on on local species Not Just Bats but
of course insects and the like
um but if there's somebody there who
wants to sit in their living room for
instance with the curtains open which of
course keep in on a nice summer evening
you could have the lights on and the
like in Into the Night what what is to
stop that that happening
um in in terms of of the local
management and in terms of the local
management as as I think we're all aware
the major issue with any kind of uh
holiday type of thing out in the
countryside it is is noise and and
impact on neighbors and
um
having the two separate parts of the of
of the site does does give me concern I
I'm not necessarily sure that the people
coming to something like this would be
the type of people who went wild parties
at three o'clock in the morning
but one never knows and and of course
with this quite rural location that
would have an impact
[Music]
yes please please do yes
um yeah yeah I we do take your points um
and concerns on that in terms of the
lighting
um as I mentioned the council
biodiversity officer has carried out the
South hams Sac habitats regulations
um
screening
um there is a question in that which is
um disturbing some new illumination
causing bats to change the use of an
area
um
she's she screened that out as a no
um if I just read out what it's what she
said the South hand planning guidance
advises that in the landscape
connectivity Zone impacts your new
illumination are only likely to have a
significant effect on the south ham Sac
writer horseshoe bat population where
the loss damage or disturbance would be
at a landscape scale affecting a network
of potential commuting routes and then
she goes on to assess it as um proposal
site is a single landscape compartment
equivalent to a single field with a good
network of alternative linear routes on
all sides
so she was satisfied
um that with the land um sorry with the
lighting condition that she requested
um it wouldn't have an impact on the
bats you know if if that was to fly sort
of down the middle of the site and
somebody put a light there
they can move over
and they'll you know they'll they'll
sort of fly around it it's not as if
it's completely you know floodlighting
the whole area picking up sort of wall
for the bats so she wasn't concerned
about that
foreign
sorry in which case I'm happy to propose
as a town okay thank you thank you three
other counselors have indicated they
would like to speak to Sylvia Russell
first followed by councilor Nuttall and
then Council thank you chairman as a tin
with counselor obviously there's been a
lot of interest in development to the
north of tinmouth and one of the reasons
why developers is resisted because of
the impact and the and on to the views
of the X Estuary and
um so far we've resisted uh applications
for development at that high point at
North timoth now
um if we can have an objection from
tinmouth this is mam head much closer to
the X history and it seems to me that
perhaps the residence concerns are valid
and should be taken into consideration
to have a development of this size uh
being expanded I know the development is
there already but it's obviously going
to be developed and enhanced to a
greater degree than it is now with a lot
more traffic and a lot more activity
going on in this really what is a lovely
remote area
thank you councilor awesome
cancer nuttle
uh thank you Chad now I'd like to ask a
question about compliance policy in in
the report you refer to policies S1 S9
S12 and you say there is some conflict
with those policies another reading of
it would say the significant conflict
with those policies How concerned should
we be about considering approving an
application that contravenes National
policy to that extent
thank you
um I mean I wouldn't say it's
significant conflict
um if you turn to a paragraph 4.4 in the
report where I um reproduce policy S1
um
it conflicts with some parts of it
obviously the accessibility isn't very
good
the road safety is not felt with
problems it doesn't conflict with that
yes you could say it conflicts with
access to services and Facilities
um
but it it broadly conforms with the rest
of the policy so it's you know it's you
have to look at the local plan and the
mppi can sort of take them as a whole
um again if there is some policy
conflict which is what we've done here
so we have identified there is some harm
in effect
um but the the development satisfies all
the other policies it does bring some
albeit sort of small scale benefit
um taking it because the existing former
use of the site that's why in this case
um it's felt that that small policy
conflict wasn't fatal to the scheme and
in fact the benefits outweigh that harm
thank you
okay thank you uh councilor Clarence
thank you chairman through you my drawer
members as a
um to 411 uh EC 11. to support the
success tests sustainable expansion of
the durian industry
additional tourist accommodation
includes self-con catering and service
accommodation campsites and Caravans
will be acceptable in principle within
adjoining settlement limits
does it really meet this criteria that's
what I'm saying
a is to expand or improve the existing
tourist locations be support
expansion or Improvement of an existing
existing tourist attraction
provide a new campsite or Caravan site
and D which is interesting involves the
appropriate conversional change of use
of a permanent and soundly constructive
building well these are new buildings I
can't understand why uh they're not a
caravan type nature having had a major
development hoisted on us in children in
a campsite these holiday lodges that
we've inspected on that particular
campsite have to sit on a very
lightweight chassis to meet the
definition of a caravan
these uh lodges that I'm talking about
are at the campsite at Coast view at
children so they had to comply with
sitting on a chassis with two wheels to
make them a caravan yeah here we see the
construction of what I call to complete
tourism
complete chalets here uh and are they
really meeting the the criteria in ec11
that's what I'm asking because it all
evolves around this definition I believe
of what is an actual Caravan and we have
had uh solicitors on that case I believe
at teambridge uh or and that that's
quite a contentious issue I would
suggest
am I correcting my assumptions
thank you Council accounts but the
officers like to respond please
I'm I'm happy to Cheryl and I both love
a caravan I think
um so Caravans are clearly defined in
the Caravan act
um I think it's 1968 version is the
latest and it's defined as something
that can be moved in no more than two
parts it's capable of being disassembled
and moved on on the public Highway and
no more than two parts there are also
height width and length definitions and
if this development is brought forward
in a way that doesn't comply with
um the Caravan act then it wouldn't be
uh within the the Realms of the
permission and the proposal that is
before you is for a caravan site if they
choose to build something that isn't
Caravans not only will that not be
permitted it will also most likely be
still liable so every square meter of
floor space that's developed on this
site would be liable for sale at the
countryside rate at 200 pounds a meter I
wouldn't want to pay sill on the
Caravans here well now that it's indexed
it's closer to 250 pounds a meter on
floor space so it's in the applicant
interest that this is very definitely a
caravan site as it's put before you if
you look at paragraph I think it was
four or was it 312 or 412 the paragraph
no underneath the one where the policy
was set out
so councilor Clarence brought us to 411
paragraph 412 and outlines the officer
view that the proposal is compliant with
ec11 because it's an existing tourist
accommodation location with the um I
think there's three holiday Cottages two
there's three on the site and then
there's two next to the applicants
dwelling so five existing so there's a
number of existing tourist accommodation
buildings nearby and this proposal is a
caravan site so in our view it complies
with ec11 or
um to take Charles Point earlier there's
sufficient compliance with ec11 that
reading the plan as a whole we don't
think there's a policy objection
I like it
I can only bring you to and compromises
a new Caravan site so you know lodges
don't to me I can't I'm finding it hard
to to grasp the fact that that a lodge
is now a caravan in effect if you're
calling it a new Caravan site how can
you do that if they're actual lodges
my understanding is that it's possible
to skin a caravan in a number of
different ways so the exterior treatment
may be Timber it may be cloud in a
number of different ways but it's still
fundamentally meets the definition of a
caravan which is that it's within the
size limits and can be split into no
more than two parts to be transported on
the public Highway
thank you what can I say to him and
thank you thank you councilor hook
thank you chair
um in my opinion this is and and the
officer's opinion this is a um a finely
balanced decision I mean there is harm
that is caused and there is benefit and
it's how you weigh those two up
um in terms of the benefit one one of
the benefits I think in terms of having
separate tourist accommodation I mean we
know there's a massive lack of
affordable rented accommodation and
places to purchase in our local rural
community and coastal towns because of
conversion to
um holiday accommodation
um these are separate so they have that
separate economic benefit without taking
away local cottages and accommodation
for our local population that is one
benefit
um there is a creation of jobs a small
creation of jobs which there is just
some discussion about whether it's been
overestimated but those people will need
to travel to this location
um which has a sustainability impact
um there's the benefit of the
expenditure of those people that will
stay here so um in spite of the the idea
that they'll just pitch up at their
Lodge and stay there for a whole week
um I imagine in reality they've got to
go and buy some food to eat and they've
they probably want to visit some local
destinations and also maybe restaurants
cafes and pubs because that is what will
ultimately benefit our economy so in
some ways we don't want them to stay
exactly where they are we want them to
go and spend their money and in reality
given the location they're going to be
getting in their cars for most of those
Journeys I would suggest so that again
has a benefit and a disbenefit in terms
of sustainability
and I think it is how how you weigh
those up and I think if you look at our
policies they can they pull in both
directions so although we've got ec11
that does obviously allow and a new
Caravan site or an expansion of an
existing one the word in there does say
acceptable in principle so there are
other policies that we need to consider
alongside and in fact if you look at 318
in our local plan it does say in the
open Countryside various other policies
will need to be considered in specific
cases to ensure that proposals are
acceptable
and where it's not possible to fully
mitigate impacts permission may be
refused so there is that scope even
within ec11 to refuse this if we feel
its negative impacts are greater than
its positive impacts and if we go back
to S1 and S9 of our local plan which
people have referred to then I think
there probably is some fairly
significant harmful impacts in terms of
sustainability
so I think it's you know it's a close
one it's how we weigh up those up I have
to say I'm coming down on the side of
um refusing this one in terms of
sustainability
um being a more negative impact than the
small economic benefit that would um
accrue thank you
uh councilor hook you've actually are
you proposing that this is um
refused
yes so we've already had a proposal from
councilor duhurst that it was this
approved as set out but there isn't a
second here for that
I'm just a comment actually
um it's the Heritage stuff uh
uh it's
4.78 I'm a bit confused on historic
England
originally
uh
uh had a problem with this and now it
seems that they haven't so I'm not quite
sure
the bit in
it doesn't quite make sense to me do
that are they actually
accepting it now with less less lodges
or they still have a problem with it
no they are they are satisfied with it
now
the only concern was the extent The
Lodges so they they no longer object
cancer
thank you judge just to come back
um firstly to just say my uh my proposal
as set out was to also have the 10
o'clock barbecues
um but but we have a policy which
supports
um Caravan sites in the countryside and
and by definition uh people come to the
southwest and Devon in particular uh for
for essentially two things one is our
wonderful Coastline and and everything
that that gives us
um and and the other is our fantastic
Countryside and
in my view that the two are are sort of
inextricably linked in the sense that it
is not possible to have something out in
the countryside which
has all the benefits of being there the
quiet the rural location uh the the the
no people in this instance uh the sort
of forested location
and at the same time have it completely
sustainable by definition those people
have got to come there uh they're not
going to come by train because there are
no Railway stations nearby and the like
they're going to come by car uh their
family style lodges so the likelihood is
they'll all come as a family in a in a
car
um and and and so
the principle of of the fact that we
support expansion and Improvement of
existing touristic attractions it is
there and also the fact we're we're
providing a new campsite uh which is um
which is also uh part of it so the
existing
um site is there with the existing uh
permanent buildings uh which are let out
um and the campsite are these lodges I
would also say that actually we have
some fantastic uh Caravan Lodge
manufacturers here in this County and
and indeed even in teambridge uh an
award-winning company here in teambridge
and I'm sure the applicant will be
looking at those in reference to
manufacturers from other parts of the
country so there we go that's
thank you
any any other members like to comment
thank you yeah I find this the most
difficult uh application to make a
decision on uh even the officer said it
was finally balanced and and I think it
is
I'm not against creating a caravan site
I'm all for caravaning and encouraging
tourism down here but I think there are
places to put Caravans and I'm not sure
that this is the right one I think the
access is
um
Troublesome and I think there'll be a
lot of movement from it which will cause
a lot of disturbance so on on
sustainability I think I'm going to have
to go against this application I I
really do think it is very finely
balanced and I'm not sure this is the
right place to expand expand a caravan
site
thank you
thank you
are you second in the application sorry
the reference made by yeah you are sorry
I thought it was a direct negative to
the original proposal but that didn't
get a second or did it no no so then our
second the refusal so second seconded by
Council of cool cloth any other members
like to comment at all
foreign
thank you chair
um
I think I I think I agree with councilor
duhurst
um that uh this application is finally
balanced but I think that there are
benefits um that that outweigh to our
tourist industry
um
it is implicit in the fact that we are a
rural District that sometimes there will
be a need for some development in in
rural areas and I know that we regularly
talk about
um
uh precedent not really being a thing in
planning and that what we want to try
and Achieve is consistent decision
making so they are a couple of years old
but I wanted to remind members
um uh of a couple of decisions that we
made in the north of the district at
Springfield and Fingal Glen so they were
both uh holiday Lodge schemes in 2019
I've just been trying to look them up
um so one was expanding um the finger
Glen Golf Course through the inclusion
of some static Caravans and then I think
the other was conversion from touring
Caravan to static caravan site and and
also the approval that was given for the
development of some holiday cottages at
dornerfield in apple pen so each of
those sites was
um in Countryside locations I'm not sure
if they're in aglv or not and there are
additional complications but the the way
that we presented the sustainability
point in relation to those sites was
um both the benefit of boosting our
domestic tourist industry so making sure
that we have a good quality tourist
accommodation available in the UK
potentially providing more alternatives
to people than than getting on an
airplane and going abroad so if we have
good quality tourist accommodation in
the UK whilst whilst you might need to
get in a car to get there it's better
that you get in a car and go on holiday
in Devon than that you're getting on an
airplane and and go to Alicante or or
wherever might suit your tastes and I
also very much agree with the point that
councilor hook made about making sure
that holidays take place in specialist
holiday accommodation and we were having
a conversation earlier this week about
the the real difficulty if you have a a
bar on tourist accommodation and with
the planning system that we have at the
moment the way that that would
um whilst domestic tourism is being
boosted as it has been over the last few
years that really does put pressure on
our on our housing stock so
um I whilst I understand the concerns
have been raised in relation to the
accessibility and therefore the a
inherent sustainability in terms of the
way that people will travel to get to
this site in our view
um
looked at at a more macro scale rather
than micro scale of simple accessibility
to this site we think that the
sustainability benefits are there and
obviously it's for you guys to to make
the decision and vote how how um
uh you think the balance comes down but
I just wanted to remind you of those
that single Glen decision and um the
donorfield one as well thank you
no well Council hook first of our main
place here
thank you chair
um from memory isn't finger Glenn next
to a main road
um and I'm not sure about the other one
right okay so so um this obviously isn't
near to a main road it's several narrow
Lanes to get to it I mean you know I
totally accept this is finally balanced
I think we all except this is finely
balanced and it
um you know I don't think Devon and our
countries I want to absorb every
possible foreign holiday that exists um
it's they're two different things
they're yes we need to try and stop
people taking foreign foreign holidays
by plane or minimizing the number they
do and encouraging domestic holidays I
don't think we can play that out through
this planning application necessarily we
need to look at this and the impact it's
having on sustainability and car
Journeys within team bridge on some very
narrow highways thank you
thank you
councilor Russell
Jenna we've talked about consistency of
decision making in sensitive areas well
we've just had refused uh an application
on a Brownfield site in the teen Estuary
uh which is obviously a site of national
importance from an environmental point
of view so here we are now uh looking at
this expanding a site in an area of
natural beauty and in in sight of the T
of the excess jury
um so does one balance the other out and
is there any consistency in some of the
decisions that we're making thank you
thank you
I've just just been past the note
decision must be made based on the
information contained in the report and
that presented to the committee not
other decisions sorry not other
decisions that may have been determined
can I just have clarification on that
please sorry yeah yeah that that's
correct yeah
that's correct members of the committee
need to consider the report that's
presented to them the information in
addition to what's contained in the
report that's been presented them to the
day obviously the responses to questions
raised and they um
are here to make a decision
um based on that information I would
urge caution about getting sidetracked
in respect of what decisions may or may
not have been made in respect of other
applications
okay thank you for that
so we've had a proposal from counselor
Jew host
that this is
accepted as set out but that wasn't
seconded so we've had no proposal from
councilor hook that it's refused and
that's been seconded by Council of coal
cloth so before we go to the vote I
think we need to define the reasons for
refusal
so cancel the hook
thank you thank
you thank you chair
um yes I'd like to refer to policy S1 a
um
and C
predominantly and then put policy S9
sustainable
um transport
[Music]
um
I haven't I'm not I'm trying to read it
now obviously it's quite long but the
relevant sections of policy S9 to this
proposal
for example reduce the need to travel
and then in particular a obviously not
near public transport cycling and
walking I don't think a realistic
transport modes for most Journeys from
this site
yep those two policies thank you and
councilor nettle mentioned S12 as well
so okay
okay thank you
so we'll go to the vote then for for
Jack can we just clarify
yeah clarify what members are voting on
councilor Jackie hooks proposed refusal
for the policy she's just outlined
um I understand you you
councilman nuttle mentioned a policy but
you know including that and that's been
seconded by cancer Club so that's what
we'll be going to the vote on okay
members thank you and and we are voting
for refusal rather than against okay so
can we go to a roll call please
thank you chair councilor Bradford
councilor Clarence
councilor kolkluff
councilor Cox
councilor Dewhurst
councilor hook
councilor Kurzweil
councilor natal
counselor
councilor Patrick or
thank you
so with one exception that's carried
isn't it yeah
that's car 80 yeah nine to one thank you
so moving on now to item seven on the
agenda which is Major decision summary
which is pages 39 to 40.
and there aren't any denominator
determination has been made for this
period so we can swiftly move on to item
eight
which is appeals decisions
but the officers like to talk us through
these please
um thank you Chad just I mentioned this
one last month it had just come in and
the Hill Drive Mason Lane decision uh
that came in uh has been dismissed and
as relevant as that is an allocated site
um part of the da2 major allocation
um but there were a number of
difficulties with that one including um
biodiversity layout and drainage matters
which which we often consider in
relation to applications at dawlish
um uh the other ones uh were relatively
small scale officer decisions so um
nothing particular to note thank you
chair okay thank you any members got any
comments at all are we happy to know
those decisions
okay thank you very much indeed
so that concludes the meeting for today
so thank you for attending
and Merry Christmas to everybody
thank you